she's here for the program also here
this morning to give us a talk on
keeping meaningful privacy and some of
the work she's done along those lines
and then we'll have more technically
focused sort of short course for the
remaining three quarters of the day
morning everybody whew thank you so I
wanted to thank the Simons Institute for
hosting the special program I also want
to thank the organizers of the program
for this moment of weakness in which
they decided to include a philosopher in
the midst I'm really excited to be here
and to follow the great talks yesterday
as you probably may have guessed I
couldn't follow a lot of the technical
work but I do often choose to sit in
technical talks because even in grasping
some of the aspects whatever percentage
that is in any given talk allows me to
do what Kobe talked about yesterday and
I'm going to continue Kirby's Bridge
analogy to say that I talk from my
philosophical language from the
philosophical ethical perspective but in
order to create that bridge it's really
important for me to be able to just
absorb some of the concerns that the
technical community has and in in that
spirit I'm now continuing you metaphor
to death whenever you build a bridge you
have to sink the piers yesterday we saw
some of that happening and today I'm
going to do something of that and use
the time that I have today to talk
mainly about the theory of contextual
integrity that some of you may know some
of you may wish you never heard about it
but hopefully that will be the start of
a broader conversation now what was it
that stimulated the theory of contextual
integrity it was this a lot of
philosophers in the 70s and 80s had
started thinking about the nature of
privacy for because of computerized
databases and so forth and they
and they dove into the concept to say
what is privacy why is privacy important
but my own approach was rather a
slightly different one which was to say
here are all these things that are going
on and of course I've updated it over a
period of time and I noticed that in
response to these things many people
jump up and down and say my privacy is
being violated I don't like it I'm
concerned about it and so while as a
philosopher I'm interested in in
conceptual clarity I was also interested
in trying to find a concept of privacy
that would grapple with the reactions
that people were having to try and
understand what it was about these
phenomena that were stirring
these kinds of reactions and so that was
the purpose now trained I'm trained as
an analytic philosopher and I want to do
this is just a little bit of the
motivation a lot of what philosopher
analytic philosophers do is we take
concepts that are important concepts you
could think about justice or freedom and
we say yes these are important they're
fundamental in many different ways I
mean it doesn't have to be ethical
concept it could be concepts like belief
or knowledge or free world and we
understand that these concepts have
accrued a lot of meaning but in so doing
these natural concepts also have a lot
of contradiction and messiness and
blurriness and so what a lot of the work
of analytic philosophers is is to take
these concepts and privacy is one of
them and say what can we say that's
rigorous but at the same time captures
the essence something really important
to people when they use the term privacy
and that's been my mission when when
we're not talking about a meaningful
concept of privacy I'm using it to to
connect with the term privacy as it is
used
as it is meaningful but at the same time
to lend some rigor to it and that's what
that's fundamental to the the the
project of analytic philosophy however
there's another step along the way and
that is communities like yourselves are
thinking about privacy in technical
terms in theoretical terms and therefore
the bridge is there multiple bridges to
be to be created and what I what I would
like to do what I'm really interested in
doing is to take the concepts that are
meaningful to people to create some
rigor around those concepts and then to
see the extent to which the concept of
privacy as its represented in the work
of computer scientists theorists
engineers connects with what's
meaningful and I think it's really
important to care about that because if
you want to make and this I think gets a
little but I won't explain you know in
detail but gets at some of the
frustration that I experienced watching
coby's definitions is that you want to
have a concept that is that can be
captured theoretically technically but
it also has to be a concept that
captures a lot of what people care about
in the sphere of privacy so that's a
mission now the talk outline does it as
follows theory of contextual integrity
which I'm going to present as for theses
a little bit of applications to policy
social science computer science and
engineering and then these hopes and
dreams bridging contextual integrity and
technical research and practice which I
hope very much will be part of what
happens if not this week then for the
rest of the time that I'm here now all
the work that I'm going to talk about is
very much
influenced by collaborators these are
some of the significant collaborators
along the way and some of them are
involved with the applications material
some of them actually have really shaped
the theory itself and guided some of the
twists and turns that the theory has
made and I should say continues to make
because this as you'll see is far from a
finished theory so let's get to the
first part four essential claims so what
I have found over the years of
presenting contextual integrity is that
the like reducing it in ways hopefully
that communicate what it's about is for
essential claims the positive claims and
then at each stage to contrast one of
the positive claims one of these
positive theses and they're there
accumulate their cumulative the fear the
theses with what it's not so in what
ways does contextual integrity contrast
with some of the dominant predominant
theories of privacy be there technical
or policy so the first of the theses and
this is the most fundamental of the
theses if you disagree with this you can
leave the room I mean all right
okay so the first one is to say that
privacy please don't use privacy when
you mean secrecy secrecy says we're
going to hold this no flow of this
information now a lot of times when you
hear people talk evenness the evenness
claimed privacy versus utility I really
want to correct people when they say
this because what they really mean is
that there's a release of information
and that people allow their like or they
you know give it up and they'll frame it
as privacy is being diminished in favor
of utility and I would rather more
more precisely say information is
released in favor of utility not to not
to confuse the flow of information with
a reduction in privacy and you'll often
see I know this is you know theoretical
crowd but when I'm when I talk with
privacy in the privacy engineering
community their mantra is you know data
minimization that's what they strive to
achieve in any you know privacy by
design and I push back and I say no it's
not about minimization
it's about appropriateness and so that's
really the beginning privacy is
appropriate flow of information and
you're probably sitting there and saying
yeah sure what is appropriate flow and
here is the answer
appropriate flow is flow conforming with
entrenched contextual informational
norms and so now we be getting into the
weeds of the theory the idea is that we
have expectations about how information
will flow appropriately and when
something happens let's say there's a
technology you have thermal imaging and
now you you know with this device you
can see through walls whether you know
the heat heating lamps on the other side
and and and we have now a disruptive
flow a flow that runs contrary to our
expectations and contextual integrity
the search the second thesis is that
appropriate flow is flow that conforms
with these entrenched expectations which
are called contextual informational
norms and of course I'm going to say a
lot more about them now what's really
important to note is what contextual
integrity already is not and that is
it's not it doesn't go with procedural
approaches to privacy
which say that it doesn't matter what it
is as long as you get consent
you haven't violated privacy and the
first let's say pillar of contextual
integrity is to say that we have
substantive norms these norms or rules
govern information flow and even if you
get consent you may still be violating
privacy and by the way you can the
information can flow even if you don't
get consent even if people refuse yeah
yes yes can can I hold the question
until I fleshed out the theory because
and please ask it again because it's
absolutely the right question to ask to
see to see how it applies in specific
cases yes what I think so let's see you
can tell me I haven't and then I have to
come back all right so now I want to
emphasize this concept of contextual
because it's very much part of the
theory and you'll see how it plays out
later on and here are built on an
assumption about the the structure of
society it's not it's not my own theory
of society but the idea is that social
activity occurs not in this
undifferentiated social space but it's
augur organized around social context
now I use the word context but actually
there are many philosophical theories
and social theories that have generated
other terms and so you have Pierre
Bourdieu who talks about fields you have
Michael Walter who talks about seers you
have people who talk about social
domains
and I want to not rest the theory on any
one of those accounts but rather just
take the fundamental assumption that we
have different social spheres and it's
nothing very complicated even you know
the law recognizes these different
domains you'll ask people what kind of
law they're specialized in and they may
you know they may say constitutional
which has to do with the relationship of
individuals to government they may say
oh domestic or family law they may say
commercial law etc so we recognize these
domains and that's all that contextual
integrity does I've regretted a thousand
times using the word context because
it's such a rich term and it's so
ambiguous but I was trying to avoid any
of those other theory Laden terms
contexts are defined by or they
constituted by it's not like there's a
context and it has this stuff it's that
the context is constituted by certain
features such as what is the typical
activities who are what are the roles or
the capacities in which people act in
these contexts and you might be a parent
in one context you might be a chief
executive in another context you might
be a consumer in the third context so
these contexts are defined by the
capacities and then there are norms
their expectations for how people behave
in context and I might add that you are
all behaving very normatively in this
context and and when people behave
differently we are surprised so the idea
of a norm is also just really quite a
basic one where we have certain
expectations the norms if you will if we
want to formalize we kind of capture the
expectations and then we can understand
when those expectations are violated
yeah
No so yeah so let's so I would love to
cannot do this I just want to hold off
for a sec because you'll see how this
all the fact that that in China they're
different norms is actually kind of
proof of the theory and we'll and
hopefully I'll I'll get to it so now we
get more into the model of our norm
what are these norms look like hello
talks about the transmission of
information from Party to party and when
you describe this transmission potential
integrity proposes five parameters for
this norm actor parameters which are
subject sender and recipient so when
you're describing a flow you need to
assign values to these parameters
subject sender recipient you need to
describe you need to say what the value
of the information type parameter is and
then there's this thing called
transmission principle which gives me a
headache but okay I think it's a very
clever thing and you'll see if you agree
all of these subjects send a recipient
information type depend on the ontology
that's given by the context so if we're
in a medical if it's a medical context
then we have an understanding of what
these information types are what the
likely subjects enter and recipients are
and and so we're expecting the
parameters to to range over those
particular values
well good good question and I'm gonna
I'm gonna get to it I feel like I'm
making all these promises and I hope I
do like if I do get to it you should say
okay thank you and otherwise you should
like okay so again what we're back to
this this is what some of the dominant
theories of privacy have tried to do and
here I'm talking about legal theories
they've tried and and some of the older
philosophical theories they've tried to
say look clearly it's you know
informational and by the way it is
informational privacy I'm not talking
about the right to you know woman's
right to abortion and so forth so we're
talking about informational privacy they
have said well the right to privacy
exists only for sensitive information so
we divide the world into a dichotomy
they're sensitive and and and they and
they believe or the underlying claim now
fleshed out in this language is to say
the whole theory will hang on one
parameter and if you just tell me that
this is a sensitive information versus
non sensitive information everything
else follows
and what contextual integrity says is
know-it-all all of these five parameters
matter subject control is not the only
parameter that matters all of them
matter so it's not so you you you
sometimes in technical circles there'll
be people who are interested in
generating access control systems as a
means that there's definitely a
resemblance and a connection between
access control or role based access but
the important thing is that if if you
guided by contextual integrity you have
to know what's going on with all of the
five parameters sometimes you want to
make a system that's less complex so you
might say okay let's hold fixed some of
these parameters were only talking about
patience as subjects and sort of the
reducing the complexity and he has just
just to give you some concrete examples
of what we have in mind with the various
parameters as you can see it's it's it's
quite it's it's not it's quite a hope
intuitive as to who these various what
the various values of the parameter are
but I want you to talk a little bit
about the transmission principle because
for many this is puzzling and the idea
of the transmission principle is that
when you have information that flows
from one party to another there are the
conditions or the constraints on the
flow of that information from Party to
party and here consent does come into
the picture because one transmission
principle arguably the most important
transformation principle is consent so
sometimes when you know once you've
fixed all the parameters what's critical
to saying that a flow is appropriate is
to say is to be able to say that there
was subject consent another one that's
very important is notice so sometimes we
may say we don't need consent like with
CCTV cameras we might say you know in
England you might have seen lots of
notices that says this area is monitored
by CCTV that's a case in which you
there's no consent but the law requires
notice but the other transmission
principles and I think that was
somebody's question where if you're
April hasn't a couple of months assuming
the government is open you will have to
file your tax returns and they will say
to you what was your gross annual
earnings and you cannot say sorry I'm
not letting you know about that or if
you're a witness in a court of law the
judge will insist that you answer
questions so coercion can be a
transmission principle and
other transmission principles like
buying and selling
sometimes you share information in
confidence as you might do with your
physician sometimes not and so we have
these expectations and we're trying to
capture the expectations but the
transmission principle is very important
and for anybody again like to get the
intuition of it I I have I've have this
particular case of people going shopping
trying on shirts you find one you love
you know you tried on you love it you
just walk out of the store so what and
what's going to happen if that happens
alarm rings love rings thank you just
checking that you're awake
because what haven't you done too smart
for your own good okay so so there has
to be some kind of transmission
principle and that is that you pay and
after you pay the it becomes own it's no
longer owned by the store it's now owned
by you and we've had a transmission of
ownership from but it requires the
payment for that to happen
yeah principal supposed to be subjective
objective is like both actors the sender
and the reception are like are we
assuming they for them it's an objective
in there I agree on that principle no
you don't have to agree so we know when
we talking about norms we're talking
about rules that govern and sometimes
you you would they would be a buy-in or
an agreement among the different parties
but we're talking about the eggman
expect the expected flows and sometimes
that may have nothing to do with the
different parties who are actually
involved in the exchange another one
that we know very well is with a warrant
so let's say the police suspect that
there's some documents in your home that
may contain some useful information to
incriminate you they can't just barge
into your home we have a rule that says
you have to go to a judge you need to
get a warrant or a subpoena what no I
think the subpoena you get from the
magistrate and then once you have it you
can get that information and so we have
these transmission principles that are
very important that we've we've devised
in order to meet certain value
requirements and that too is a
transmission principle you can authorize
transmission sometimes the flow of
information is reciprocal like when
friends chat when you go to the
physician the physician is requesting
your physical information you're not
talking to the physician and
well how's that back of yours I hear you
injured it
there's no reciprocity in that way here
are just some kind of contrived examples
that show the ways in which if you
fleshed out the norm in in concrete
terms this is what they look like and
hopefully there's no surprise there so
information yeah yeah yeah and that's
and that's important for me to emphasize
which is the transmission principle is
just that it sits within the norm the
norm is describing the flow with the
various parameter the values for the
parameters set and one of them is the
transmission principle constraint no no
there's nothing
normative about it it's a purely
descriptive notion it's it describes how
and why information no why just how it's
the conditions under which the
information flows it flows under these
conditions
this one
so it seems like these transmission
principals like cover lots of different
things and and that it's not clear they
all like are the same type you know for
example if the in confidence part seems
really to be about other flows yes it's
a unique voice it's a condition
it's a condition it's like a future
constraint on the flow and what I wanted
I'm gonna move on but I am gonna put a
pen in this and say that this is this
continues to be work because in some
loose account of the transmission
principle the numbers of transmission
principals can explode indefinitely and
while I have very strong intuitions
about some of them I'm just not sure how
to keep all of them out of the out of
the gate you know so yeah
something that is verifiable you know
it's like a car if you're right under
which the transmission is allowed or
stealing maybe more so seeing what so
you're saying that that some of it for
some for to in order to call this a
stealing rather than a whatever else you
need to know some extraneous information
the this you can't capture everything
about the law the transmission principle
with information like non-moral
information and and this it's actually I
don't know Koby if some bells are going
off but the question often with myself
and computer science colleagues is to
say how much of the work can be done in
the program and how much of it has to be
done
external externally to the program will
you fix certain conditions beforehand so
that you can give an interpretation of
what's going on in the program only
after you have done some labeling
outside of it I mean I think that this
is a fascinating question just generally
now I'm not answering that that's too
hard because we'll get it yeah which
actor is the one that determines which
no actor except if it is one of the
transmission principals let me please
let me move because because it could it
could well be that you have a debate in
society I'm not these are not see this
is what this is really important it's
actually an important feature of
contextual integrity which is that it's
not interested in preferences it doesn't
see information flows as flows that
people like or dislike
it's about societal expectations that we
absorb for instance if you're applying
for the for a job and they ask what
grade you got in you know C++
programming and you got a D you may not
want to give that information but it's
required by the circumstances and so
that's potential integrity wants to talk
about the norms not about that now
they're important this important work
that tries to get at what people's
preferences are but what we want are
more like expectations and judgments you
wouldn't be shocked when they asked you
that ok I see as the fraca actually say
what it is even if it's easy I'll answer
it what you just said at the very end
reminds me of one of the questions you
asked yesterday to the present is from
Google ever on Google Chrome and things
like that right is it would you say that
you curl the that they are spaces
currently were some of the term on we
see about privacy is because there are
norms yet yes yes they aren't they are
norms yet when they're contested and now
and and the fairy will theory has
something to say about it
and again what wind copy when you
started your Tokyo
today and you said what were the use of
the cases that you were testing us our
intuitions okay coby's TC is positive
and you said you know is this okay to
reveal this information and people said
yes no whatever and I'm sitting them
saying you haven't finished that
question released to you under what
conditions you know I can't answer a
privacy question unless you fill out all
the parameters and they probably are
some assumptions people are making and
what this I have now a series of three
studies this was the first one with
Kirsten Martin in which we try to reveal
that actually people's judgments
predictions expectations of privacy
really do depend on more than the
parameters then then we're giving them
credit for and so in this work this was
the first of them we we decided to focus
on information that was was judged to be
sensitive and so we we went back and we
redid a study that the Pugh group had
done Pew foundation about what
information people consider to be
sensitive and the our results were the
same you know when you just ask people
to adjudicate sensitivity of information
Social Security's like
way-off-the-charts health phone
conversations email are the most and
then we focused on those and then here
are the other ones the thing what we did
using a method the curstyn is the
empirical expert and she's coming to the
workshop at Stanford I'm happy to say we
added parameters to the question and so
even though people were kind of similar
in how they judged health information
when you said your physician or you know
a store it's the health information how
many people are shocked that there's
enormous divergence in whether people
thought that this was okay by the way we
always like would you like it no we try
not to ask it that way we try to say you
know is it okay because we tried to get
at norms not at preferences it turns out
that it's actually very hard to get at
it and I'm hoping that at that workshop
we'll will kind of learn how to ask the
questions so that we get back what we
want and what we need but you can see
that you can't tell the whole story
without specifying who the recipients
are and and what the transmission
principles and so forth are and we did
something very similar with information
that was held in public records to show
that even though we're dealing with
information in public records people
show that they have wildly different
expectations depending on how you fill
the parameters and anybody who followed
the whole story with Kobach wanting to
get voter registration information which
in most states is public information and
in fact whether you voted in the most
recent election is public information in
the sense that it's in a public record
people objected to it quite vociferous
leave now this kind of guy I think this
is going to address maybe a question you
asked which is you know what what work
is this this norm structure doing and
it's doing two-fold work one or can do
two-fold work one is as a descriptive
mechanism so if you're building a system
of some kind and you want to describe
the information flows my suggestion is
that you describe the flow you flesh out
the flow in terms of
all these parameters in order to give a
comprehensive flow that is going to be
relevant to people's judgment as to
whether privacy has been respected or
not you can use this particular norm
structure as a descriptive mechanism if
you want to describe practices you can
use this structure to describe those
flows in ways that will be useful to the
next step
oh and I think this was your question
you if you want to judge whether a given
flow isn't is acceptable or not you
measure int norms like rules which are
prescriptive so what we say is you ought
to the flows ought to resemble and they
ought not to violate this but this
particular flow that we know to be
entrenched in a certain context so I
think it does both jobs now pausing
there for a second I mean I don't know
this this was just some slide that I
wrote up where I thought you know how
does this particular philosophical
theory connect with some of the work
that's going on in computer science and
engineering and I'll confess or probably
evident to you in the audience that I've
done less work with or hardly any work
with theorists and people in who are
experts in differential privacy and I'm
really really interested to figure out
are these competing theories are there
ways that each of them complement the
other how can they be useful to each
other and of course it's not only
differential privacy but there are other
ways in which cryptographically based
efforts to protect privacy how do they
connect up with a theory like contextual
integrity so I mean I'm not going to
read everything there but I'm just
assuming that while I'm talking you've
been reading it ok and not your email
so here are some of the applications
that we have done so with Deborah Estrin
we were looking at these so-called small
data applications this is this is a pain
management applications and from doing
that work we developed this kind of
visualization technique to map data
flows this is for like a ridiculously
simple app and you can see what goes on
and what's helpful then is to see kind
of leakage of information in unexpected
ways even to the developers who were
saying for convenience let's just use
you know Google authentication the
Google sign-in and then we were like
well do you know what information flows
when you use this particular API and
they were oops No so the visualization
helps people map out the data flows this
is very early work really it was for me
it was eye-opening because at the time I
was working on contextual integrity as a
philosophical theory and I was part of a
big NSF project and I had presented this
to the large group and John Mitchell was
in the audience on a pump data and they
had an idea that you could take these
norms and formalize them and they
developed a formal policy language and
then later on an app um and his
collaborators and Michael chance has
been part of this effort as well to to
look at we looked at the
gramm-leach-bliley act we looked at I
was not part of this project we looked
at the HIPAA but what's really
interesting about this I I like this one
in particular because it's like a
covered entity those are those are the
the capacity those are the actors in in
within that are governed by HIPAA like a
hospital or physician and so on
Candice low disclose a
patience psychotherapy notes to the
patient only with prior approval from
the patient's psychiatrist so in that
that's another case where consent is not
the sufficient condition for data flow
but you need the approval of this
additional so that's you know
identifying the transmission principle
and it's turned out that conditional
integrity was incredibly useful for
doing this work except for one thing
that was really missing and that's
another thing that has to be part of the
next phase which is that there was very
much use was a parameter it was just
clear that you could do you know this
flow could happen only if it was used in
the following way and we conditional
integrity I'd always fought and said no
we don't need the six parameters I think
the five we have a perfectly fine thank
you very much and now I'm increasingly
thinking that we actually do and one of
them is related to a question that
somebody asked which is that we have a
host of new actors in society the
platforms for example that don't have a
thousand years of history for us to
learn what the appropriate flows of
information are and so use becomes
really an important parameter in the
situation in which we find ourselves now
so I'm just going to you know put a pin
in that some Warkworth systems people
trying to create some data leakage
protections that's based on contextual
integrity in a group of three of us have
done a survey of some of the work that's
yeah on the previous slide
my hands I was getting up I'm sorry did
you put that up there to ask you because
I think I'm missing something about what
what's the sort of virtue of this formal
policy language because that seems like
a very strange construction to me and
then it has this sort of like veneer of
mathematical rigor of you know for all P
which you know if it's for all P that
are an element to the bar or a rational
number like I know what we're talking
about but if you are psychiatrists all
of the analytical loose enos of plain
English that gets there so like why this
like half mathematical language like
what does I came to accomplish yeah and
I think this connects a little bit to
Chevys question which is that some of
this we're gonna have to what we care
about is float information in society
and this will allow us a way to
potentially embed some of the
constraints within a system of
information like information flow within
an organization or between different
organizations that could be government
or health insurance companies and
hospitals and so forth so you you trying
to do it if you have an inclination to
automate this flow then you might use
sentences like this to to then describe
the constraints in a language that the
computer understands but in order to
then enforce this with the real world
you need you are going to need some way
to represent the various parties like
psychiatrists
in the internal mechanisms of the system
itself and that step may or may not be
able to be internalized so for example
I'm going to take you away from this and
just am something where it people are
trying to make that connection in a
technical way if you have your you know
your iPhone in creating a biometric that
where you press your famine it knows
it's you what we've done here is we've
created a link between something that's
flesh and and messy and or that and we
now have a representation of that that
now the system can grasp in the
languages that it with with which it
operates so I don't know this is a grand
philosophical point I'm going to I have
like one huge chunk that I have to get
done before I finish so can I just put
it on hold
don't look so sad okay all right
so this is the partner magnet and that
is like we all know that what I've just
told you is an incredibly conservative
theory I've said that flows have to
conform with entrenched norms and now
we're all sitting then saying oh my god
everything that we know about digital
technologies is that they challenge
entrenched flows that we do different we
do things differently and now contextual
integrity seems to say if you don't do
it the old way then it violates
contextual integrity and so we need to
have something else we need to say it's
true that at a first step and this is
like a default condition that if it
respects the entrenched norms yay but if
it doesn't what do we do about it
and the answer is that this
so many of these conflicts and by the
way there's nothing new about norms
changing in society over time I think
we've seen some massive normative
changes in our own even within our own
lifetimes so we shouldn't be surprised
about that and what the aim of
contextual integrity needs to be it
needs to give an account of not only the
norms that are entrenched which we can
perhaps discover through empirical means
by by surveys and interviews and looking
at law that seems steady law there
multiple anthropologically and by the
way you know getting to the question
that you asked what what this will show
actually is that when people say our
privacy is not a human right because
look you know this society believes this
and that society believes that
contextual integrity says yes that is
exactly how it should be there should
not be a universal set of norms from
culture to culture as long as their
fundamental differences in the
organization of those societies so we so
instead of entrenched the idea is we
need some way to do an ethical analysis
to arrive at to figure out when you have
a conflict or maybe as I think somebody
mentioned the information flows that we
didn't even dream about and therefore we
don't even have norms for them who had a
norm for seeing through walls we didn't
have that because we couldn't do it and
so we have to have some way of doing
performing an ethical based analysis to
get at what the legitimate contextual
norms might be in some of these cases of
conflict or some of these absolutely
novel cases now what contextual
integrity proposes is that there
different layers of analysis that one
can do there's an in to look at
interests and preferences of affected
parties now a lot of politics and a lot
of marketing
does this and then it stops and we know
that issues of fairness are dealt with
at this level you know tourney of the
majority and so forth so the next layer
of analysis looks at ethical and
political principles and values and here
I refer to fantastic work that's done by
my colleagues in law and philosophy who
asks a question what is the value of
privacy
it protects freedom it protects autonomy
you know freedom of speech and fairness
and non-discrimination so we look at
that but the part that I'm going to just
dwell on for a moment is the contextual
functions purpose and values because
when I was describing context to you I
didn't do a full job of it what I didn't
say is that you might even say
constitutive of the context are its
purposes if you go to a school and
you're not told that this is a place of
learning for whatever those purposes are
in a different society you know creation
of future citizens or development of a
workforce you don't know what a school
is and so contexts are defined by their
purposes and also you can think about
values as constraints so physicians
would like and maybe in some senses
they're limited to provide health care
irrespective of financial wealth we you
know our purpose is to make a society
more healthy alleviate pain prolong life
blah blah blah and we do it it doesn't
matter what your salary is we do it
equally and so the non-discrimination is
a value of the healthcare context and
functions are you know functions within
the context in order to promote the
purposes and values so what becomes and
this again I think will address some of
the concerns people had is that privacy
is not a
about the individual private we protect
privacy when we say likewise privacy
important why should we so again you
know listening to talks on differential
privacy local local locally provided
provided at always at the back of my
mind is that the only way or homomorphic
encryption the only way these are going
to work is if you can get all the
parties to buy in and the only way
you're going to get the parties to buy
in is if they all agree that privacy is
important and one of the commitments and
again this is a fundamental commitment
of contextual integrity rises or falls
on this which is that privacy is a
societal value and it makes societies
better not only the lives of the
individual data subjects so
privacy is not always contrary to
utility just wanted to get that one in
here are just some examples of purposes
and values and one thing that I would
say it's like when we have these
societal debates about what to do you
know should facial recognition
technology be used by commercial actors
I want to argue that the people we need
around the table are not only the
privacy experts we need the area experts
that can take in education it shouldn't
only be the legislators it shouldn't be
the computer scientists it shouldn't be
the philosophers of privacy it should be
school superintendents it should be
people who teach it should be parents it
should be everybody who cares about
education and what the purposes of an
educational system ah unless I love to
use I use it I think in every talk I
give her in contextual integrity which
is just kind of an interesting
historical case where Andrew Mellon was
trying to persuade I think must have
been Congress to take tax records and
make them confidential and he doesn't
say oh you know this is to be nice to
individuals this is going to protect
them it's rather to say the Treasury
will suffer if rich people have to
double to the earnings so if we make it
confidential they more likely to
honestly say what what they've earned so
here we are
privacy required this is a summary that
actions practices and policies conform
with legitimate contextual or privacy
norms this was just some ideas of the
fields of computer science
well maybe yes and I know of a few very
specific cases where I think we're all
cursing that particular thing I mean it
was just interesting that the argument
to persuade it was was that so I think
that if we look at the ways of enforcing
contextual integrity representing it
within systems making sure that certain
flows happen or not happen I have been
you know worked with people or I have
dreamed about some of these areas of
expertise coming into the particular
mission and I'm just going to stop with
this slide as a summary slide and I
would love to take Adams question this
so is prepared to okay but anyway that's
that's what I'm gonna talk about
[Applause]
questions just back to the quote for a
second when you have that you were
talking about confidentiality and I
haven't heard you use that word in there
it's in your framework that is an
important distinction between privacy
and confidentiality or well I think I
think of confidentiality as a
transmission principle and then privacy
is will well so it it's about that
little hop but not about yeah
just to extract a sense of context or
integrity give some kind of framework in
order to persistent define some kind of
blueprint according to which the
information flows soon what it should do
does it say anything in case of course
something's gonna go wrong and one of
the particular knobs will be violated
does it say what should happen to the
others is there a way to do that um you
mean actually cheating then does it say
all the policies that should react no no
I mean it it again depending on where
you're gonna put the enforcement you
could and and I mean depending where it
may be that all you can do is audit a
system I mean if you like it you can
order it and then you and then you might
let's say I send you an email that says
confidential and then you forward that
email just to give you a kind of normal
sort of case then it could be that in
order to try and enforce these norms
your system would monitor and then it
might complain to the bla bla and then
you might lose your account so like some
of that punishment might happen or what
we want to try and do with vaccine is
actually anticipate and and actually
block some of those actions and a lot
and it gets you know it gets back to
this question of of that connection of
human and the representation of that
human in the Machine how well you can do
it how much work does happens within how
much work two questions one was about
maybe the
the easier one first is there a way that
the within the kind of language you have
to talk about the extent to which people
understand the transmission principles
at work especially where transmission
principles are about like future
disclosures or future transmissions
right you know for example you know I
click on an ad I may not understand that
information is recorded it's tied to my
you know my identity it's used in the
future to show me you know decide what
other ads to show me whatever that is
sold to other people
you know to what extent is that the
limits of people's understanding of the
context yeah fold into this type of just
remain whether with a description like
whether I mean that's just as a matter
of how you take your system up it seems
like it's fundamental these notions of
norms in evolving and when technology
evolves yes because if I don't
understand you know something that is
like the way that the flow is described
to me will change the way whether or not
I feel it is yes violating consecutive
contextual norms yes and so it seems
like one of the sort of important
parameters that it seems our thuggin all
to this way of describing things is like
how much the people involved be they
subjects or senders or recipients
actually understand what's going on yes
yes and this is part of the struggle
over policy privacy policies that the
ongoing I don't know is that surprising
to you I mean he's like where does it
fit into your script like I don't see it
no it doesn't it doesn't fit in in the
sense that my what I would my only thing
I can
response used to say when you're
describing to people the flow make sure
that you mention all of these things and
now possibly use as well if I'm a
company that sells it for me like again
I'm not sure if it may be no so yes no
it's not yes yes and no so some of the
work that we're doing at the moment is I
know like everybody and their brother is
like analyzing privacy policies but
we're doing some large-scale work
looking at privacy policies and showing
that some of like say Facebook's Privacy
Policy has virtually like if you look at
how you would spell it out it has
endless possibilities of who the
recipients could be these are open-ended
the way they are saying what's going on
with the flows so all we can do from the
from this theory is to say look we think
people need to know this your policies
are nowhere near doing this lawmakers do
something about it
I don't think the marketplace is going
to I don't know I feel like am I not
getting it that I'll let maybe other
people follow up on that I know that's
my other question the the way you
describe flow at the very beginning and
this maybe gets to Kobe's question about
infringement yeah I wanted to get this
for lack of a better word atomic flows
where you know information are our data
in the original sense of units in you
know indivisible units that are moved
around their records they abstract there
there are abstractions the norms are
abstractions but yes what we're looking
at our particular flows of they govern
particular units if you will a flow of
certain information pipe from Party to
party okay I guess my question is how
fundamentally would you one have to
rewrite the theory to take it
flows that don't have that atomic flavor
so it for example inferences made based
on seeing many aggregate statistics or
things like that
there's a question okay so how to what
extent would it is it possible to fold
that into the current framework or to
what extent with the framework need to
be you know extended change
so when you say aggregate statistics
you're saying that whatever this
property is it's you're saying Adam
almost always yeah yeah no but no I want
to talk okay I want I want to talk about
yes yes yes that's an exact same thing
say the sum total of your movements in
public right kay that's something that
there's not a moment of transmission
that like here's everywhere I've been
for the last month
okay one moment where like in an
information theoretic sense like I that
doesn't have to be one moment no sir no
I think I'm not sure that that's what
Adam was exactly yeah if based on your
activities yeah that looks like
activities of others on the platform to
who additional information is available
yet right this is not a piece of
information that you gave that keep the
inference piece yes and yet with that
piece of information on you right is
that Adam I I don't I'm not by the way
so I think it still doesn't get at the
at the some of the really challenging
inference questions not by the way I
have a paper at the that's not yet out
it's called contextual integrity up and
down the date of food chain and it
grapples exactly with some of these
inference questions but when if on the
basis of a bunch of observable
information I based on
aggregate information I might infer
whatever that you have cancer then we
now have a dead we have a flow in the
same way I don't know the target case
has gone through so many iterations and
now people believe that it's it's false
but that I've observed the hand creams
that you buy and now I will share
information that you're pregnant it's
not so much that it comes from the data
subject the sender could be but if we
have a norm that says this flow is is
contrary to societal expectation that
red flag is going to be raised and and
here atrophy I see as do you want to
intervene do you want to interject in
the discussion because as you say that
they are because because they what is
what do you want you know you want that
if you're in danger information if in
danger is not a picture it's processing
of information then a determination that
some professionals as they passed so and
then you're willing so I think it's
related to discussion because let's say
that this aggregate indicates page oh
then you might say that's a societal
value which I'm willing
whether you can hold it up I don't know
if you did you might say that that's
okay exactly
thank you I mean you know that really
makes that helps me make this a couple
of points not not to get to the heart of
the concern which is that it's not just
it's not just the transmission principle
it's not just the data but it's the
purposes that are served by certain
flows of information that's what you've
just outlined when you've said to save a
life or you know whatever it is we're
showing that it's dependent on these
various factors so I mean I'm all on I'm
all on board with that and that's is
sometimes how we change expectations so
maybe Hippocrates says you know you
shouldn't ever share anything you've
ever seen and now you know in this day
and age we know their contagious
diseases we know their restaurants that
sort of toxic foods and and so we have
to alter that you know entrenched norm
that had some very good rationale behind
it to something else that does a better
job of meeting the contextual functions
and purposes now in terms of just to
just to wave a hand because this is like
a whole nother discussion
what about inference especially in these
days of big data and machine learning
and so forth because what happens and I
think that this is what I see is the
crux of it that we have these norms that
maybe they allow certain flows of
information but
taken the information that flows very in
acceptable ways but when you accumulate
all that data together you can draw
inferences that violate norms and
expectations at least they don't conform
with these expectations because
sometimes what we discover is just like
my god ID I don't even have a norm for
it in the old days we were able to when
these sorts of things happen slowly
enough you know you had a you had a
scientists in performed experiments
controlled experiments and we discovered
that if someone has a mole that looks
like this then it's most likely
cancerous and then we maybe update the
norms of flow so I think social security
number was a case in point
social security number was was was it
was just a number
wasn't it sensitive but suddenly when
people started attaching social security
number to many other factors because it
was convenient you could use social
security number to aggregate and as a
matter of fact it could be used to you
know to perform identity theft and it
became all of a sudden we want to know
why social security numbers off the
charts in terms of how people judge it
sensitive we've had a radical chat we
had over the years a radical shift in
our expectations regarding social we had
time to get the publicity out that said
hey you know don't reveal but nowadays
the discoveries through these mechanisms
of big data and machine learning I don't
know how I don't know whether I'm not
sure whether we can update the norms
fast enough and I think we have to go
with what with what I think you were
suggesting although you know in a very
specific way is that we need some
means to challenge the function and the
in service of what values we need to and
that's also like some work that I'm
doing with some political philosophers
to figure out this issue of legitimacy I
don't I don't know that we can use the
norms in some of those and maybe maybe
Adam you were trying to get at some of
those difficult questions and I know
that Kobe this is great concern am i
right so I think integrity norms are
rules about how information could be
transfer the use but these rules don't
but in my presentation yesterday I had
put a focus on that the privacy concept
would not would also have consequences
to informational files and so on and the
FATA privacy has some of this flavor and
so it's not a rule it's a framework for
thinking and analyzing privacy of
mechanisms and for example with the
theme that the information that - we
used was published then in a way that
matched the norm the rule the rule was
just you should strip off this
identifying information hence because
everything was according to do I don't
see what was broken is if they know
what's about not about what we should do
but what the concert was we should be I
could say that the gnome was you know
bridge so I think this is a one one
issue I have what were the Furious is is
that it's very hard to say okay we have
the rules but how does that actually
protect our privacy it is probably in
places where the rules were you know
throughout the years I have you know
evolves to actually be good rules in the
way the woman looks like things are
changing so fast it's not clear that
these rules are still what we should
pursue and have you look at norms in
terms of not I'm not sure that i
disagree except with what the goals when
you say the goals you're saying maybe
privacy but I'm saying the goals that we
need to look at the reason that certain
rules if you look historically why is it
that we had have the norms we have we
can like his look historically and say I
can just I can explain why these rules
were good but I can also explain why in
you know hundreds of years later these
rules need to give way to other rules
but not just here in my view are the
goals and the values and the purposes
this not privacy these other things and
I don't know if you if we disagree on
that but I can see Adam getting agitated
and everyone wants their coffee in
yeah encourage further discussion during
the and we've got you know we